Hi Leute!
Heute gibt's mal ein Maskenvideo von mir, ich sehe ja aktuell
sind Masken überall ausverkauft und sie werden ganz teuer auf eBay verkauft.
Und ich zeig euch heute einfach, wie ihr in 30 Sekunden eure eigene
"Atemmaske" herstellen könnt, ganz günstig und ganz schnell.
Dafür benötigt ihr einfach ein Stück Stoff, das kann z.B. auch ein sauberes Geschirrtuch sein.
Oder ihr nehmt euch einfach ein T-Shirt und zerschneidet das.
Das ist jetzt hier freundlicherweise von Hamza zur Verfügung gestellt worden,
ich fands auch nicht mehr so schön!
(H: *lacht*)
So, und jetzt haben wir die Größe, das sind 25x30cm zur Orientierung.
Und jetzt schnappt ihr euch einfach dieses Stück Stoff und ihr könnt das
hier umklappen je nach Größe, je nach - wenn's ein Kind ist,
macht es kleiner. Wenn's ein Erwachsener ist, dann halt ein bisschen größer.
So und jetzt nehmt ihr euch einfach ein Haargummi und geht einmal bei beiden Seiten ran
und könnt das hier zwei Mal oder ein Mal so verengen.
Das gleiche von der anderen Seite auch nochmal.
So! Und jetzt braucht ihr eigentlich nur noch ein Stück, das ihr an eurem Ohr befestigen könnt.
Da nehmen wir uns jetzt wieder zwei Haargummis und gehen hier einmal rein
und verbinden die Stücke, das geht ganz einfach.
So. Das gleiche von der anderen Seite auch nochmal und dann haben wir's!
So, das war's schon, fertig ist die Maske!
Einmal aufsetzen.
(H: Sieht doch fresh aus mit den Streifen!)
Jaa, siehst du? So, hinter's Ohr.
Und fertig! Sitzt, wackelt und hat Luft!
Perfekt!
:(H: Perfekt!)
So, lasst einen Daumen da, ein kostenloses Abo und dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten Mal
mit einem leckeren Rezept oder einem Vlog!
Tschüss!
(H: Oder bei Kaufland mit der Maske!)
Oh ja!
Tschüss!